(poop death music in the background) I have never been this disappointed my own editor my own flesh and blood
Have conspired against me. They made a video behind my back
Called "How to get Into LWAIY"
Where they make fun of me :(((
WELL JOKES ON YOU BRADS
I'm making this video and I'm editing it myself!
I BET YOU WEREN'T EXPECTING THAT, HUH!??!?!?!
Basically doing the work that I pay them to do, for them.
Good Job Felix.
Got Em'
You really got em' Felix
I'm editing this video to PROVE THAT I DON'T NEED YOU GOSH DARNIT (christian channel)
I also have this new setup; It's a little confusing
Which one is the real poo dee pie?
I can't beleive I- I have to react to this
but let's see what my editors have to say about me...
Brad 1: Myself and Sive who is also known as Brad 2 or Sive 1
Brad 2: uuuhhhh It's Sive 1 bruh stop hatin' Jesus- you're Sive 2 man, alright?
Brad 1: I'm Sive 2, but I'm also Brad 1
Pewdiepie: Does that make me Brad 3!? hehehehehe (claps)
yay! haha